many rumors many many years ago about
you
and rihanna did you guys ever date can
we set the record straight now
no rihanna and i never dated thank you
doesn't that feel good to get the truth
out
there i was never i was never pretending
i was never playing koi
no no there we go i'm writing an article
on an operation goliath
you can either tell me what really
happened or you could squander this
precious opportunity
let's talk about the movie because i
really loved it actually
you've been in this business for over 20
years now
so what is it about about a script that
kind of
draws you in this one in particular it
was
i mean i'm always i'm always looking for
a film that
is being shepherded in through
production
by uh by a passionate director i read
the script and i was like this is really
interesting i'm from minnesota i'm from
basically canada and i've never heard
anything about this this is such an
interesting story of corruption and and
uh
obviously you know a horrible thing that
a young young man went through and
it just didn't crack into my
into the news in the states at all and
so i was amazed by that but then i met
with the director talked with him
and his passion for it was was so
evident
he's so full of energy and he asked me
to come up and meet victor mallory who i
play in the
play in the movie and so i was living in
new york at the time i flew up to
flip to toronto and we victor showed me
around all his old haunts he showed me
his old desk at the globe and mail we
met a bunch of people they used to work
with
and brought me to his old house and
showed me pictures of his kids and all
this stuff it just sort of like
really gave me a sense of who he was at
this point in his life and i was just
about to have my first child
and was just immediately like i was like
i have to play this guy
you can't publish this it could blow up
in our face
i'm writing my article you can put on
the front page or not so you did meet
victor did you ever get a chance to meet
or talk to elaine oliver
elaine was on he was he was on set a lot
and i'm glad victor wasn't there because
victor was there i don't think i could
have done my work was there an added
pressure to almost
bring this story to light and also to do
it justice because it's based on a
on something that really happened
absolutely i mean whenever you're
playing somebody
i've played a few real life people um
that pressure is there because you want
to be
well there's it's twofold you want to be
good to the person that you're playing
but you don't want to be too good
you want to be honest victor's a guy who
you know we'll see what he thinks
for real in his next book government
abandonment
am i supposed to leave him out there to
rot you have a ton of other projects
coming up but i feel like a few years
ago
you sort of took a step back from
hollywood
maybe possibly what is your relationship
with hollywood like these days
my relationship is good with hollywood i
i have
i think when i was younger i was
fighting against a concept i had of
myself within the industry and i didn't
like
maybe the way that i i didn't feel like
the movies that i wanted to do i was
being offered and the movies that were
being offered to me were
then of course i couldn't do those
either because i wanted to maintain my
integrity and just go after so i started
to produce my own films and i did
smaller
uh independent projects and and people
took that as a sort of
me throwing away a career or something
but it wasn't that at all in my opinion
it was
it was me sort of just finding myself as
a young man in this industry and trying
to make something myself that wasn't
just
what was basically you know set out for
me you know making my own decisions was
very important to me
uh from a very young age so i
yeah i mean i did take some time off
took some but i
but i mostly took time off to do other
things like raise my children and
you know like i started to write a lot i
wrote a few scripts
i wrote a few shorts and did a few
directed a few shorts and
music videos and started producing stuff
so i i wasn't like i was never
inactive i was just doing other things
but the story is yeah that i'm
i'm i'm some recluse that her mouth
content or something
but i but i've never felt that way so my
relationship with hollywood is what it
is it's always been just sort of
me doing the thing that i want to do and
trying to make sure that i can do it if
i can
you know it's difficult to make movies
in this industry if you're trying to do
personal films
luckily i've i've been able to come in
contact especially recently with a lot
of really passionate filmmakers and
and people that are kind of on board
with what i
you know with hiring me to play the kind
of roles i want to play and so i've been
kind of lucky these days you mentioned
raising your family and you have three
kids who are how old what how old's the
oldest one now
uh really young four and a half wow
three kids
under age and four and a half what what
quarantined
life like with yeah are you
homeschooling them or
they're probably a little bit too young
for that four and a half is just below
the cutout for homeschooling so we got
lucky
but we do we do teach them you know
obviously
everything we believe they need to know
at the time but it's not
it we don't have a curriculum we need to
follow which i hear is very difficult
from friends
so i i uh yeah i feel lucky that
we were able to just sort of enjoy our
time together and not force them into
these
you know situations that were going to
make us all the family dynamic fall
apart it was it was busy we were
juggling
we were juggling a lot as they get older
will you let them follow in your
footsteps if they
so choose to act it's hard to say
i don't i see the thing is i was i
didn't
want initially to become an actor i
sort of fell into it in a way so i don't
understand the whole
pursuit from a young age thing but my
partner was a young actor and so she
and and she says no she thinks that they
shouldn't
be doing it at a young age so i think
when they're adult when they're adults
they can do whatever they want but in
the meantime we would we would hold them
back
yeah do they get who mom and dad are yet
too young for that no they don't even
know
my oldest is just starting to understand
that like i i do something that's like
she thinks i might be the voice in the
disney movie or something you know like
she doesn't see actor driven films you
know
she sees she sees animated films so
if i'm going to make a movie it must be
one of those she wonders why she can't
see me
does she have a disney movie hopes for
you
i think she does yeah recently she sort
of started to
ask me why i can't make movies that she
can watch
i think world war ii just started
changing gears a little bit i don't know
if you know this but next year marks the
20-year anniversary of pearl harbor
do you still keep in touch with anyone
from that cast i mean
ben affleck kate beckinsale jen garner
i think alex in that movie there's a lot
of good people in that movie and i do
see people occasionally but no we're not
like we don't have like
a whatsapp group or anything what do you
remember most about making that film i
mean it was such
an amazingly well done picture
it's a romance isn't it and what i loved
about
making the film was that we were in
hawaii making a historical
epic romance and
i my my grandfather and my
great uncles were all world war ii and i
came fully prepared with all of their
letters
like had all this sort of research into
the time period
and then uh michael basically told me
that michael bay basically just
told me that he's like what what why why
are we talking about that like you just
go over here and run away from that
explosion and you know like see your
lines
it was just like you know it was it was
a different experience than i expected
it to be
but i was young and naive and now i get
it a little bit more yeah
still still a good experience though oh
we had a great time
yeah yeah like it was extraordinarily
lucky making that film we had
an enormous we had a lot of time first
off we were in hawaii for most of it
everybody on it was really lovely all
the other actors were great
and uh yeah i mean it was it was
it was it was epic it was an epic
[Music]
experience